건물 위치도 그렇고 지금 건물
컨디션이라 매입하는 그런 루트까지
봤을
[음악]
때는네 안녕하세요 사입니다 어 제가
오늘은 최근에 눈물의 여왕 드라마가
굉장히 좀 인기가 많은데 요번 주에
마지막회라고 합니다 거기에 나오는
김지현 배우님이 빌딩을 2021년도에
매입한 사례가 있어서 오늘은 그
사례를 한번 준비를 해봤습니다 김지현
님은 2021년도에 좀 매입을 했어요
그래서 그때 당시 같은 경우에는 딱
불장 초입인 거 같아요 위치는 서울시
강남구 노현동 매입을 했습니다 지금
보시면은 여기가 합동 사거리 여기
이면에 이쪽 건물을 내입을 했어요
건물 모습은 지금 이거고 그래서
21년 매입 이후에 따로 이렇게
외관상 손을 버거나 그런 거 같지
않습니다 원래 위에가 이제
주택이었는데 요것만 좀 도 변경한
것으로 좀 보여집니다 항상 건물
검토할 때는 토지 이용 계획부터 봐야
됩니다 토지 이용 계획을 보면은 이종
일반 주거 지역이에요 저희
구독자분들은 바로 아실 것 같습니다
건폐율 60% 용적률 200% 그래서
보면은 건폐율 46% 용적률이
202% 예전에 지은 거에서 조금
오버 돼 있어요 딱 연면적이 꽉차
있는 그런 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 원래는 상부측에 주택이었는데
용도 변경을 했고요 보이시죠 21
1년도 10월 28일 날 용도 변경을
했습니다 그래 4층이 원래
주택이었는데이 변동사항도 한번 보시면
좋을 거 같아요 대장상에 엘리베이터가
따로 기재는 안 돼 있는데 실제로는
한번 가서 봐야 될 거 같아요 주차
내대로 돼 있고 용도는 다 이제 근생
시설로 돼 있습니다 2011년도에 어
법인 명으로 어 건물을 매입을 했고
지금 채권 최고액이 한 42억 정도
돼요 그래서 실 채무액은 35억 정도
어 될 것으로 예상이 입니다 63억
원에 매입을 했으니까 한 28억
취득세까지 감안하면 한 30억 초반
정도의 실투자금이 들어간 것으로 좀
예상이 됩니다 그래서 우선 제가 일단
또 보고 느낀 점은 뭐냐면 법인
명의로 매입을 했는데 제가 법인
등기부를 떼서 보니까 설립일
2016년도 그라고 그래서 여기서 또
하나 아셔야 될게 법인 설립한지
5년이 지나고
과밀억제권역내 본점이 있고
과밀억제권역내 부동산을 매입할 때
만약 5년이 안 되면 취득세 증가가
되는데 지금이 법인 같은 경우에는
5년이 지났잖아요 21년도 매입했으나
취득세 중간은 따로 안 받은 것으로
좀 보여집니다 어머님이 이제 감사로
계신 거 같고 본인은 이제 어 대표
이사로 돼 있습니다 보니까 그 나이가
되게 어리시고 그래서 지금
92년생이 저랑 한 살 차이납니다
믿기 힘드시겠지만 어 2016년도에는
어 25 살이었어요 그때부터 법인
설립을 해 해서 계속 엔터테인먼트도
유지하면서 부동산 투자까지 생각을
했던 거 같아요 대출도 제가 봤을
때는 좀 좋은 조건을 잘 받은 거
같아요 대출을 좀 말씀드리자면 부동산
임대 법인으로 돼 있는 법인은 대출
조건이 좀 안 좋습니다 한도가 좀 덜
나올 수도 있고 대출 금리가 되게
높아질 수도 있거든요 이거 같은
경우에는 어찌됐든 엔터테인먼트 업을
하고 있으니까 만약에 사황 목적으로
매입한다고 하면 은행에서 굉장히 좀
좋게 봅니다 제 예상 컨대 대출
조건도 좀 잘 받았을 것이라고 좀
예상이 됩니다 그래서 좀 이렇게
뒤져보다가 도대체 언제 대비한 거지
2016년도에 법인 설립하면 도대체
언제 대기지 해다 보니까
2010년도에 롤리팝 혹시
아시나요
눈 어 저도 이제 학창 시절에 참
많이 들었던 노래인데 어 롤리팝 여기
CF 나왔더라고요 어 한번 찾아보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 되게 빨리 대비를
했고 이때가 아마 쯤인 거 같습니다
한 6년 정도 뒤에 엔터테인먼트
회사도 설립하고 5년 뒤에 이제
취득세 중가 요건이 끝난 다음에
법인으로 어 빌딩 매입까지 한 그런
사례입니다 김지현 님은 되게 좀
준비를 잘하신 거 같아요 정석대로
잘하고 계신 거 같습니다 개인적인이
사례를 좀 보면서 느낀 점은 위치가
좋은데 너무 잘 샀어요 제가 되게
좋아하는 곳입니다 도산대로 바로이면
심지어는 학동사거리 바로 이면에
건물을 매입을 했고 몇 적도 좀 어느
정도 있는 건물이고 지금 손 보진
않았지만 조금 공사도 하고 하면은
임대료 수준도 되게 좀 높아질 만한
그런 건물이고 취득세 중가 요건
지나고 5년 뒤에 어 이렇게 빌딩
매입까지 한 것으로 좀 보면은
정석대로 너무 좀
베스트하비 보자면 건물 위치도 그렇고
지금 건물 컨디션이라 매입하는 그런
루트까지 봤을 때는 굉장히 좀 준비를
잘 하고 성공적으로 하는 그런 투자
사례라고 좀 생각이 됩니다 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 어 요번 주에
마지막 표 잘 시청하시고 어 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]